محمد رمضان يجدد التاكيد انا نمبر وان هو
بين ام السلطان حامد وام جعفر العمده صفصف
الملكه هاله صدقي تبدع في رمضان ومن بعد
دفعه بيروت ناصر الدوسري بطل في دفعه لندن
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
النجم محمد رمضان من يوم ما قال انا نمبر
1 والجدل حول الموضوع هذا ماهدي ولكن هذا
الشيء عمره ما منعوا انه يستمر في تلقيب
نفسه بهذا اللقب والتاكيد على الموضوع
كمان واليوم عنده حلقه جديده من حلقات
التاكيد على ان الرقم واحد فبالتزامن مع
النجاح الساحق لمسلسل الرمضاني جعفر
العمده نشر محمد رمضان على حساباته خبر
انه هو اول فنان عربي هاشتاق اسمه يوصل 9
مليار مشاهده على تيك توك محمد رمضان مو
بس اعلان عن الانجاز لكن كلامه اللي قال
فيه لو سالوني تختار مين غيرك اول نجم
عربي يوصل للرقم ده ويستحق لاني بحبه من
صغري وبحترم مشواره ومجهود وفحقول عن
جداره محمد رمضان اللي هو انا برضو فعموما
احنا فتحنا تيك توك نتاكد من هاشتاق محمد
رمضان ولقينا انه فعلا هاشتاج اسمه عليه
اكثر من تسعه ملايين او تسعه
للاعلى محمد بن نجاح للنجاح اكيد
[موسيقى]
ومن بعد مشاركته في دفعه بيروت السنه
الماضيه بدور خلدون بيطل علينا النجم
السعودي الصاعد ناصر الدوسري في رمضان
بدور مقداد في مسلسل دفعه لندن الشاب الذي
يواجه مشكله بسبب صديق وسلطان وبيتعرض
للخيانه من عشطار
السعودي الكويتي العراقي
في الميه
مثل ما قلنا مشاهدينا النجم صاعد والمنصات
لمسه تطور في اداءه وتمثيله سنه عن سنه
وعمل عن عمل
وينضم الينا من الكويت ناصر الدوسري اهلا
فيك معنا يا ناصر ومبروك الجدل والنجاح
والكل بيتكلم عن المسلسل
الله يبارك فيك ساره وكل عام وانتم بخير
ومبارك عليكم
يا رب
المشاهدين وخواتنا وان شاء الله يعودونك
كل سنه بصحه وعافيه يا رب امين ان شاء
الله ناصر انت يعني منتقل من دفعه لدفعه
من دفعه بيروت انتقل لدفعه لندن وكيف وصلت
لدفعه لندن
خذينا البكالوريوس وكملنا بالدكتوراه واضح
انه هبه مشاري وحماده يعني عاجبها انها
تحطك ضمن الدفعات يعني طبعا ايش اللي صار
كيف قالوا لك انت تعال شارك معانا في دفعه
لندن وايش قالوا لك عن الدور
والله للامانه اول شيء حابب اشكر للكاتبه
بشري حماده على اختياري في في دفعه لندن
خصوصا في شخصيه مقداد كلموني وانا كنت
اصور في لندن عمل
قالولي نحتاجك في هذا الدور فلما قريت
الدور يعني متعب جدا كاتبه يعني كاتبه اول
مره ينيدور مكتوب في تفاصيل عميقه
وحالات نفسيه عميقه
اشكرها في اختيارها لدور مقداد هو يعني
اللي بيتابعوا المسلسل هم عارفين انه
مقداد مسحوق جدا يعني بشكل مو طبيعي ويمكن
انا وانت تناقشنا في الموضوع هذا وقلت لك
قديش انه انا مستفزني مقداد هل مقداد
لكرامته طيب شويه
والله هو ما ابي احرق بس هو راح يبين
بشخصيات او يمكن مبين بشخصيه اليوم اللي
هي حلقتناش بين شويه مقداد
بالكلام اللي يقولوله لاصحابه لما راح
يوصلها البيت عشتار ما خلاها فز قلبه شوي
بس ما قلبه عند اي احد عشان لا يمسكون من
مكان اللي عوره
قدام راح تشوفون يعني راح يصير انفجار
عالي ممتاز ان شاء الله لانه يعني انا كل
ما بتفرج كل ما بكون مستفزه جدا والناس
ترى على فكره اونلاين كلهم جالسين يتكلموا
على هذا الموضوع وحتى شفتها في التغريدات
يعني انه ننتفض مقداد طب الناس اصلا من
البدايه ورجعوا كمان كانه عاملين ثنائيه
بينك وبين روان مهدي وعملك سوق كتير صور
وقصص حب واشياء زي كده بتتابع هذه الاشياء
يعني
بيروت مع دفعه لندن بس والفنانه اوجه لها
تحيه فنانه جميله
وفي لو يلاحظون في ابديت يعني شوفونا مع
بعض من دفعه بيروت لدفعه لندن بس شخصيه
مختلفه اكتب مختلف تماما عن دفعه بيروت
وان شاء الله دوم انا وروان مهدي نمثل لنا
للحين ما شبعنا وعندنا اشياء وايد نبي
نطلعها حق الناس
[موسيقى]
مشاري حماده الاختيارنا
الناس بعضهم يعني طبعا بيتابعوا المسلسل
وكل الكلام ده كله زي ما انت عارف في مديح
وفي جدل وفي النقد بعض الناس قالوا انه
انتم مطلعين او الشباب طالعين بصوره يمكن
خلينا نقول انه لا تمثل الشباب الكويتي
لانه مثلا في سكر في بنات فيما الى ذلك كل
هذه الاشياء وانه كانه ما هم رايحين
للدراسه كيف بترد على هذه الانتقادات
كل واحد عنده انتقاد بالعكس الشيء السلبي
والشيء الايجابي كل واحد يقول رايه بشكل
عام
وناخذه بصدر رحب ونستمتع ونسمع الصح ونسمع
الغلط نسمع كل شيء بالنسبه احنا قاعد نسوي
حالات الطلاب
حياتهم الطبيعيه كثر ما هي الدراسه نشوف
الاكشن وبالنهايه احنا دراما لازم شويه
نفتح فيها الخطوط هذه مبين شلون الخليجي
او العربي او ايا شخص يسافر لندن دراسه
طبعا عنده اشياء بره فيها اكشن فيها حب
فيها اشياء سياسيه فيها دينيه فيها ايا
كان انه حياه يعني واكيد تابعت كمان الجدل
اللي على الموضوع انه الاساءه للمراه
العراقيه
نعم شفنا والعراق تاج على راسنا واحنا
نغار على العراق وما
احد يغلط عليها
هذا في ناس مختصه يقدرون يردون على هالشيء
اكثر من ناصر واكثر من اي ممثل زملائي
اللي موجودين
وتابعوا يعني لا تحكموا من اول الحلقه او
ثاني حلقه او اخر حلقه راح تعرفون شنو
الخطوط رايحه او شنو الجنسيات رايحه لوين
يعني كل صراحه ايوه فعلا كل ما تكلمت مع
احد من المشاركين في هذا العمل كانوا
بيقولوا انه اصبروا على الحلقات استنوا
شويه على الحلقات وحتشوفوا يعني انه
بزياده يعني تفاصيل اكثر طب الناس اللي ما
بنشوفك في اعمال سعوديه
والله وقت وانا قاعد اصور دفعه لندن جاني
خمسه اعمال سعوديه خمسه اي نعم
هذول ماني قادر
ادخلنا يمكن يساوي 5 اعمال اللي راحت
اخراج اخوي بدر شعيبي بطوله اخوي ابو عبد
الله بدر الشعيبي ناصر عباس فرح الصراف
رهف محمد عبد الرحمن اليحيوح من انتاج
شركه ترند برودكشن وتروح تكون على مسرح
صارت الدعيه صارت اليد شارع الحب مسوين
شيء مختلف تماما
عائلي الكبير والصغير راح ينبسط فيه
هاله صدقي نجمه من سنين منوره الشاشات لكن
اللي جلسه بتعملوا فينا السنوات الماضيه
مو عادي ابدا هذه السنه جرعه التالق معالم
الضعف كمان اكثر واكثر عملين بتشارك فيهم
هلا صدقي في رمضان في سره قلبها اتشرف
بدور ام السلطان حامد اللي بيلعب دوره
احمد السعدني مشاهدها قليله لكن الدور
ثقيل جدا ومؤثر انا بقول لك انساها ياما
مش عايز مش عايز حامد مصيره ومعروف
عن دورا في سره الباتع انه لو كان رئيسي
كان اخذت فيه جائزه افضل ممثله ومخرج
العمل ومؤلف وخالد يوسف قال انه عندها
مشهد في الحلقه الاخيره من العمل يخلد في
تاريخها وتاريخ السينما وهل ردت وشكرته
وقالت انها سعيده بالتعامل مع مخرج محترف
مثله اما الدور الثاني لهاله صدقي واللي
مكسر الدنيا في حرفيا ومن اول حلقه فهو
دور ام جعفر العمده الست صفصف الست اللي
دخلت قلوب الناس من خفه دمها وكلامها اللي
زي العسل
انت ور
حكايه الجواز دي عارفه مين اللي خده
[تصفيق]
ومعنا من القاهره النجم الملكه هلا صدقي
اهلا فيكي معنا يا هلا وكل عام وانت بالف
خير ولا الملكه صفصف تحب النادي لك خلاص
الملكه
خلاص يعني وصلت القمه الان هلا ايش اللي
عملته فينا هذا رمضان انت اسطوره اسطوره
اسطوره اسطوره في هذا رمضان
الحمد لله يا رب يعني هو نمبر وان مين
هتخلفه يعني ملكه
فعلا
فعلا فعلا
تبقى امه حاجه مش عاديه يعني ملكه تخلف
نمبر وان
يعني انت انت متابعه الناس قديش بتتابعه
اللي بتقوليه واللي بتسويه واللي بتعمليه
متابعه ردود الفعل
ردود الفعل وفي دراسه مسابقات على صفصف
وجرايد مهمه كاتبه اكتب مميزات صفصف قوي
احنا خمس اسباب انت حبيت صفصف ليه او قولي
عيوب صفصف يعني همم الحديث في ناس عايزين
يعملوا عرايس صفصف بس هو صفصف ما عندهاش
عيوب اصلا
لا طبعا لا طبعا دول مش فاهمين يعني بس
يعني هي يعني ده هي هي
بتتميز يا ساره
بالتواضع حقيقه نعم وانها عفيفه اللسان
وعفيفه اللسان
انا بقول لك ترى انا من اول لا انا من اول
رمضان انت ايقنتي واسطورتي خلاص صفصف هي
ايقونتي وعلى فكره انا امي اسمها صفيه
انا امي كمان اسمها صفيه وادلعها صفصف
يعني كمان ماشيه الامور تمام معنا
هلا محمد سامي قال انه اصلا قبل ما يكتب
الدور ده كان بيفكر فيك انت ايش معنى
ما اعرفش هو لقيته في يوم كده بيكلمني كنا
في السيف قال لي بصي في دور كده في دماغي
وانا مش لاقي حد يعني مش بفكر انت بس اللي
قدامي مش مش اي حد ثاني
قولي لي دلوقتي اكتبه ولا لا قال لي انا
عندي مشكله انك ام لمحمد رمضان قلت له انا
عملت قبل كده امي لمحمد رمضان وعادي طبعا
قال لي لا في له اخ اكبر فانت سن اكبر
فقال لي دي المشكله الوحيده اللي عندي قلت
له دي بالنسبه لي مش مشكله خالص لان احنا
بالميك اب نقدر نعمل اي حاجه
وانا بالنسبه لي مش انا ممثله اعمل اي دور
بس هو الحقيقه الهدف كان عندي من زمان ان
انا عايزه اشتغل مع محمد سامي فانا هشبط
حتى لو عامل لي واحد عندها 100 سنه كنت
هعمله عشان محمد سامي
والتعامل مع محمد رمضان يعني زي ما انت
عارفه
يعني قلنا اوكي يلا يلا بدا يكتب بعث لي
تريتمنت قلت له حلو تمام
عملنا بروفات واشتغلنا الحمد لله والتعامل
مع محمد رمضان يعني انت عارفه كل الاشياء
اللي الناس بتقعد بتحكيها على محمد رمضان
وكده انت مثلا بتقولي انه لا نمبر وان
وانا امه والملكه وكده يعني واضح انه
انسجمته فعليا
لا احنا منسجمين جدا وفي كميه قويه جدا
بيني وبين رمضان وبيني وبين محمد سامي
ومحمد رمضان بيبقى هو اصلا ممثل قوي لكن
لما يبقى قدامه ممثل قوي محمد رمضان بيضرب
في 10
يعني انا لاحظته في اعمال كثير ان محمد
رمضان لما بيبقى معاه ممثل ضعيف
بيقعد يشد يشد معه علشان يبقى على درجته
او على مستواه لكن محمد
يعني كل مواهبه بتبرز بجد لما يكون معه
ممثل قوي
بتختلف تماما بتزيد
لانه هو اصلا ممثل بس الحلو في الاصل طيب
انا حابه بس نعرض خليل كليب من
لطيف هو في اللوكيشن بصي يا ساره هو بني
ادم بسيط جدا متواضع جدا بيحب زمايله همم
مش اناني مش مش منافسن زي ما تقولي يعني
في ناس يقول لك الله دي احسن مني دي
المشهد بتاعها محمد رمضان مش كده محمد
عايز كل الناس كويسين ودي مواصفات النجم
ده عايز كل الناس كويسه في كذا احد وصفه
هذا الوصف عشان
ايه في ايه
اه في بيت لكن في في في ممثلين او ودول
بيبقوا عمرهم قصير بيبقى هو اللي عايز
يظهر والباقي يموت حواليه انت قلتيها صح
ايوه محمد رمضان مش كده
جاي متناقش مع محمد سامي لو في اي حاجه
بيسمع كلام المخرج مش شايف ان المخرج هو
اللي له الكلمه اللي في الاخر اللي تقول
اه نعمل ده ان هو ده اللي شايف في نجوم
عندنا كتير قوي ممتازين لكن راحوا راحوا
في الوبا ليه لان تدخل في التصوير تدخل في
الانتاج تدخل في الاخراج بيموتوا
تحبي تسمي لنا اسامي يا هاله
لا طبعا لما اشوفك بقى ههه
منتظراكي على نار
طيب هاله خليني بس بدي اعرض كليب ونرجع
نتكلم
جايه جايه لك بكره
في المطار نستقبل نستقبل الماضي الملكه في
المطار خليني اشوف الكليب ونرجع
اه
احلى
مش كده
خلصتي يا جماعه
[تصفيق]
يا استاذه كان شرف والله العظيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني هم بيقولوا لك كان لنا الشرف نشتغل
معك تقولي لهم طبعا مستمره في اداء صفصف
يعني الاضافه طبعا الكلام طب الكلام اللي
بتقوليه هلا هذا كله كان مكتوب في
السيناريو
اغلبه اغلبه اه اغلبه يعني انا اضفت حاجات
بسيطه طبعا روحي وطريقه ادائي
لكن طبعا في حاجات اه وفي حاجات هي اساسا
مكتوبه وفي حاجات اضافها محمد ده بقى
الكيمياء اللي بيني وبين محمد سامي في
اللوكيشن انه بنطلع حاجات هو بيطلع حاجات
وانا ساعات بطلع حاجات هو ساعات بيوافق
ساعات بيقول لي لا لان هو اللي شايف اكتر
في ساعات بنقول لكن هو في في المجمل طبعا
محمد سامي وانا طبعا في شويه تاتشات
بتاعتي طبعا
يعني اولادك ايش كانت رده فعلهم على
الانفجار هذا اللي صاير حوالين المسلسل
والله هم في الاول ما حسوش لغايه ما بقوا
العيال في المدرسه بيدوروا عليهم عايزين
يشوفوا اولاد صفصف
حبايبي اتخضوا
والعيال بقى عايزين يصاحبوهم وعايزين
يجولهم البيت عايزين يتفرجوا على سفساف
وكده
فالعيال قالوا لي العيال في المدرسه يا
مامي اختلفوا قوي وكله عايز يجي يصاحبنا
وعاملين ويقولوا فين اولاد صفصف ولاد صفصف
ويعني
كانوا مخضوضين شويه لغايه ما قعدتهم شافوا
صفصف بقى وفهمه يعني لقوا عندهم زمايلهم
حافظين الديالوج وحافظين الحوار
اهتموا بقى بعد طب هلا انت يعني عامله
حاله خاصه في جعفر العمده بس بعدين اللي
بيقلب القناه مثلا او بيروح يشوف مسلسل سر
الباتع بيشوف هلا ثانيه مختلفه تماما هلا
يعني قمه في الاداء بس اداء يعني تراجيدي
ودرامي بحت كنت بتصوري في نفس الوقت ولا
يعني قديش صعب انه قدي كده الاختلاف ده
كنت للاسف بصور في نفس الوقت
وكنت بحاول افصل لان طبعا شخصيه صفصف كانت
مقصره علي قوي لغايه دلوقتي مقصره عليا
لكن طبعا انت كممثله لازم بتفصلي يعني انا
ما عملتش قصه ان انا اعمل عملين مع بعض في
وقت واحد ده من سنين طويله جدا انا بعمل
عمل واحد فقط في السنه
لكن طبعا فرصه ان خالد
يرجع ثاني يشتغل
وخلي يوسف انه ينزل تلفزيون اول مره انا
عارفه دي ممكن تبقى اخر مره لان عندنا في
البرنامج قال انه ما راح يكرر التجربه
شفتي اهو من غير ما اعرف ههه الاسبوع
الماضي كان ضيفنا وقال لا اخر مره
لا لانه خالد جه على نفسه قوي لانه هو
المفروض يبقى فيه مخرج معارك المخرج بتاع
مظاهرات وتحريك مجاميع
يعني المفروض يبقى معه بتاع اربع خمس
مخرجين للحاله اللي هو عاملها
الحقيقه الاستاذ خالد تحمل المسؤوليه كلها
يمكن لان طبعا انتاج مسلسل زي ده مش سهل
وما تعملش مسلسل تاريخي من ايام صلاح
الدين الايوبي وعلى التلفزيون كمان صعب
صعب
ومرتبط بوقت ومرتبط بمواعيد
والحكايه مش سهله يعني هو لما نزل نزل في
حاجه في منتهى الصعوبه
لكن طبعا دي كانت فرصه مش ممكن اضيعها
والحقيقه من من حلاوه الديالوج
والصوره اللي انا شفتها في الايام اللي
انا رحت فيها اصور كنت متضايقه جدا وعلى
المونيتور يعني انت حرمتنا عشر سنين من
الشغل ده لان احنا
مفتقدين ناس موهوبين حقيقيين على الشاشه
وقلت له انا لو كان دوري دور اساسي ورئيسي
في المسلسل انا متاكده ان انا كان لازم
اخد جائزه احسن ممثله بس هو كان ضيف شرفه
وده كان شرف كبير لي ان انا اشتغل في
مسلسل هلا احنا ما حسينا انك ضيفه شرف
انا بتابع المسلسل انا ما حسيت انك ضيفه
شرف لانك محرك رئيسي
بصي هو لما يبقى 15 حلقه في 30 حلقه يبقى
ضيف شرف بس انت لان يمكن دور ام احمد
السعدني والمشاهد كانت مؤثره جدا صراحه
بس هو ضيف شرف للاسف طيب على العموم انت
يعني انت في اي شيء حتى لو عملتي مشهد لو
عملتي مشهد واحد انت نجمه انت الملكه صفصف
برضه يعني في نهايه اليوم بس ربنا يخليك
طبعا طبعا طيب هلا السنه الماضيه نحن كان
عندنا لقاء وقت مسلسل فاتن امل حربي وانت
كنت وقتها برضه مكسر الدنيا في هذا الدور
واتكلمنا في موضوع وقتها حابه اذكرك فيه
خلينا نشوف الكليب ونرجع نتكلم
اذا انت اللي بتتكلمي عنه كمان يعني جزء
منه شيء شخصي انت مريتي فيه
طبعا انا لسه
بمر فيه لسه شغاله يعني الحمد لله
انا بصي المسلسل هيخلص مسلسل مش هيخلص
لا ان شاء الله
[ضحك]
انا واضح انه 120 حلقه
مكمله شويه في جزء ثاني ثالث وكده ان شاء
الله ربنا ما يقطعها عادي يا حبيبتي
[ضحك]
هلا المسلسل انتهى
احنا طبعا بنتكلم عن قصه طلاقك وسنين
طويله موضوع الطلاق طبعا
بصي انت وشك حلو عليا بس لانه انا انا
طبعا مش عايزه اقول لك انا تعبانه ومجهده
قد ايه لاني انا من الساعه ثمانيه الصبح
في الشارع وطبعا نازله من سته ونايمه خمسه
لانه احنا الحمد لله الحمد لله الحمد لله
تم خلص الموضوع الحمد لله
والنهارده بالتحديد
رحت غيرت اسمي في الرقم القومي همم الاي
دي بتاعي يعني وغيرت الباسبور وغيرت كل
الاوراق يعني كل الاوراق القديمه اترمت
والنهارده كل اوراق جديده الحمد لله خلاص
نقدر نزغرط لك الان على الهواء يعني
اذا انت بتعرفي تصغرطي
الطلاق تم من اربع شهور او ثلاث شهور بس
برده
[موسيقى]
يمكن ده يا ساره اداني طاقه في الشغل يعني
اكيد اكيد لانه كان في حمل في في دماغك
شغاله في حاجات تانيه مش قادره تركزي
يمكن
والحمد لله النهارده اوراقي كلها جديده
ممتاز الف مبروك دبي باوراق الله الله
حياه جديده وشخصيه جديده يعني يعني فعلا
فعلا هلا انت كنت متشائمه جدا في السنه
الماضيه قلت انا مسلسل ما راح يخلص
اه بس سبحان الله شوفي كيف سنه فرجت بس
الحمد لله الحمد لله ما عندكيش عريس يا
ساره ههه
هلا انت ناويه تعيديها شر ناويه تعيديها
ناويه تكرر التجربه
المفروض الدرس كان صعب شويه النهارده بنتي
النهارده
لا لا بنتي النهارده عماله تزن عليا في
القصه دي طولها بس يا ماما بس يا حبيبتي
لا لا الحمد لله الحمد لله
ربما انك خلاص ما تبقي عريس احنا منتظرينك
في دبي تجينا وتنورينا
والملكه صفصف وحنطبل لك وحسوي لك كل
الاشياء اللي بتحبيها هلا يعني وعايزه
سجاد احمر ولا يهمك ولا يهمك
طلبات صغيره دي يا هاله طلبات صغيره جدا
مش من دي جايه لكم
يا ماما ايه بقى اكيد لا انت هتنورينا هلا
انا اتعب وانا اقول لك انت قديش نجمه هذا
الرمضان انت اللي عاملاه في سر الباتع
وجعفر العمده فعليا شيء فوق الخيال عدا عن
انه انا بشكل عام اصلا انا احبك يعني
كمشاهده انا احبك انت وشخصيتك وكل شيء فيك
يعني وادائك وكل حاجه يعني
فقلوب من دبي الى القاهره الى انت تجينا
ان شاء الله على دبي ونشوفك وننبسط بشوفتك
شكرا لك يا هلا على وقتك اليوم ان شاء
الله ميرسي يا ساره اشكرك ميرسي ميرسي
من يوم حلقته مع رامز وصحه الفنان محمد
فؤاد شاغله الاخبار والمنصات واليوم في
تطور جديد بيزيد القلق حولها للي مو متابع
من كم يوم ان عرضت حلقه من برنامج مقالب
رامز وكان الضيف محمد فؤاد وفي اول الحلقه
قال انه عامل تكميم معده من 15 يوم لكن
بعدها رامز كمل المقلب وكان مقلب الغساله
وكان في يعني خلينا نقول هز وخذ خذها في
الاخر شفناك محمد فؤاد ماسك جرح وفي دم في
يده وبعد عرض المقلب طلع الدكتور
واتهم رامز وطاقم البرنامج بارتكاب جريمه
وقال انه كان في خطوره حقيقيه على حياه
محمد فؤاد ويعني هاجم البرنامج باشد
العبارات لكن ارجع حول البوست لخاص بدل ما
هو عام وقال انه محمد فؤاد كلمه وقال له
انه كويس وخلاص الجديد اليوم انباء
متداوله في وسائل اعلام مصريه بتقول انه
محمد فؤاد تعرض لاصابه في العمود الفقري
من بعد مشاركته باحد الرمضانيه ونروح
يسافر على المانيا في تسعه الشهر علشان
يتعالج ومع انه ما تم ذكر اسم البرنامج
لكن الناس كلها قالت انه المقصود هو
مشاركته في حلقه رامز نيفر اند محمد فؤاد
للان ما في نفي او تاكيد منه للاخبار لكن
متداول كلام على المنصات انه اطمن الناس
عليه وقال انه صحته جيده وما اشبه شيء
يعني الاموره تمام رغم الكلام المتداول
هذا عن محمد فؤاد وتاكيده انه تمام لكن في
ناس لسه قلقانه وبتستشهد بفيديو نشره
الفنان والنقيب مصطفى كامل واللي كمان كان
هو ضيف في برنامج رامز والناس بتقول انه
كلام محمد فؤاد في الفيديو دليل انه صحته
مو تمام
دي انا وانت بعد بعد ما هزرنا في مقلب
سقيلة ديسكو جنه بلاوي كل سنه وانت طيب يا
حبيبي
النار بالنار مسلسل لبناني سوري بطوله
عابد فهد جورج خباز وكاريس بشار وطوني
عيسى وزينه مكي والعمل من تاليف رامي كوسا
واخراج محمد عبد العزيز ومن اول ما طلع
هذا العمل عامل حاله جدل كبيره بين
السوريين واللبنانيين وتعليقات كثيره بين
اتهامات بالجراه في الطرح والترحيب
بالموضوع وبين اتهامات ثانيه باشعال نعره
العنصريه بين البلدين والشعبان اول الجدل
بدا بمشهد كان بين كنيس بشار اللي بتقوم
بدور مريم اللاجئ السوريه اللي هربت من
سوريا واستقرت في لبنان وبين جورج خباز
عزيز اللي بيكون مدرس موسيقى انطوائي شفنا
في المشهد الشخصيه السوريه اللاجئه بتقول
للبنانيه فينيقيا وهو بيرد بطريقه ساخره
انه ما حنكتب لكم بالفرنسي لانه ما راح
تفهموا امس جرعه الانتقادات والتعليقات
زادت بعد مشهد جديد المشهد ايضا لكريس
بشار وفي بتروح تتصور على شان تطلع جواز
سفر لبناني وبيطلب منا المصور خلع اعجاب
علشان تبين لبنانيه بحسب النص المسلسل
كاتب المسلسل رامي كوسا من بدايه العمل
المشارك في الانتقادات والجدل وبينشر
بوستات بينتقد فيها تعديلات كثيره في النص
وزاد الانتقادات اكثر بعد مشهد امس وقال
انه الجمله اللي قالها المصور انه ما راح
تبين لبنانيه مو موجوده ابدا في الحوار
اللي هو كتبه وانه تمت اضافتها من قبل احد
ما يعرف مين هو لكن اكيد بموافقه المخرج
المخرج كان طلع امس في منشور على صفحته
على فيسبوك وقال انه كل التعديلات اللي
صارت كانت بمعرفه الشركه المنتجه وكل شيء
انحذف كان من ضمن البروفات علشان تناسب
توجهات المشهد
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم
دائما تابعوا اخبارنا على صفحاتنا على
مواقع التواصل وطبعا الحلقه كامله موجوده
على شاهد اعتقد انه حلقتنا اليوم جميله
اللي ما لحقها لازم يلحق يرجع يتابعها
الموجوده وعلى يوتيوب كمان موجوده كامله
واحلى شيء ان انا امدح حلقاتي مشاهدينا في
امان الله
[موسيقى]